you
and we're just in time barely and I'm
very happy to say that mr. spinal tap is
in there very nice I see a lot of yeah
most of you are saying that the color is
purple that's how I see it
okay so we have mr. spinal tap
round one opponent this hourly super
blitz when's the last time we played
three two what was that at marathon no
not a marathon oh yeah well exchange
dark square bishop just gonna go in for
it voluntarily no wanna be a pest
so Bishop takes now if I take with the
Queen there's this kind of nonsense so
let's let's get a center and see how
spinal tap addresses it
okay I'm gonna hop in I want to stop
Bishop to g4 so we're gonna do a fancy
night reposition and this is pretty much
always useful isn't it my king is happy
okay challenging the d5 pawn all right
I'm expecting b6 and then Knight to c5
no okay maybe just some b5 idea okay
which one of my pieces could improve
tell you
I don't want to see b5 this night could
improve I should uh I should be
answering my own questions here let's do
this I don't want to invite the bishop
on this diagonal I'm not liking my
decision with uh maybe rook to c1 or
maybe even this questioning a lot of
moves and there haven't been very many
so far in this game okay so my knight is
under fire I think I could do this
Knight takes Queen takes Bishop takes
there's Knight b6 with the fork I don't
think there's any fantastic Bishop move
mm-hmm and what more yeah this guy is
just out of play yeah and do something
that looks weird I don't know I don't
want this rook to kind of see the world
wonderful reasoning all right these guys
are kind of at a standoff this is a
fiend cutout Knight never really a good
sign okay yeah insisting on improving
that Bishop I understand for sure mmm
okay I might be going in for an exchange
sacrifice I may have to yeah I don't
think I could tolerate that so we're
gonna we have some some play with the
minor pieces fortunately let's see if we
could work some magic I do have a
connected passer because of that
exchange about even on the clock I think
yeah this Knight there really isn't a
better square is there a good square for
this night I have pressure
around the center this pond could bolt
and why not just winning upon here
Knight c6 is a nice square am i just
following for some tricks here let's put
the knight on c6 rick is gonna get
active my bishop could get super glued
in there soon Bishop on b5 I think this
is for sure compensation um let's just
step up wow I didn't even realize that
that a knight could be captured and why
not why am I not seeing that I don't
know is this really gonna hurt me the
Queen sliding into f3 let's just defend
some stuff well I don't think I have to
rush I want to knock out the rook yeah I
just want to kind of cut off the rook
for a moment I want that pawn to go any
further I'll see ya that pawns ready to
bolt let's get my pawn to a6 how about
yeah let's do this
hmm okay I have coordination actually
with this move I think I'm better now
until that my was played it's a bit
irritating and a kill me here down I'm
clock oh that's a big pond to lose a
really big pond
a really big pond for seconds it's not a
lot two seconds I have this oh my god
don't ask what happened oh my god I
should stop this stream right now and
play the lottery
lucky dropping pawns my opponent doing
helpmates and stuff
Queenie 7 let us start that was one of
those where how do you explain it
can't explain it huh what was I gonna
say yeah that I don't I don't want a
four to open the Queen side up too soon
I don't play it a bit more conservative
what was I gonna say yeah that exchange
sack what what to say about it I wish I
had more time to think that one through
do I happen the center I think I'm cool
with getting one piece off yeah now I
know I'm in this pin but should I am I
really concerned about that okay let's
go back to once here and you're gonna go
for more exchanges okay let's go here I
want to stay off as c6o d5 doesn't hit
with tempo just gonna keep I have to
have to watch out for this pawn and
let's let's go here see what happens
maybe I take and then uh try and do
something along this file okay the
light-square bishop Sargon do I take now
take once and then play a let's say
Queen C for take like that I'm gonna
take like this that way there's not as
many options to recapture and I think
I'm cool with this both of these
structures are interesting and that the
Dark Star bishops are under control yeah
so yay or nay to the Queen exchange I
don't know what white should do I think
that should be avoided because I'll gain
control over the only open file so that
must count for something so am I not
getting something good now first I want
to control the night I don't think
there's any rush with the C file I think
any potted move on any pawn move I just
lock it up there's no fear of this I
just give the knight a shove and now now
I think we want to pivot here keep
pressure on something so one work off or
and I don't know what what light should
do okay so both rooks are gonna be a bit
passive yeah let's get to the second
ring good things that things happen
improve the knight say here here here
here the night is not helped in either
case how about we do this well I could
have gotten here too
I don't know if I even want to take that
pawn though oh let's not do that I think
I want to just go here Flight Square and
I'm ready to prove my king I'm not
exchanging both rooks I'm way down on
time is this a move
I'm just gonna try and keep it simple I
need to I need to be a bit more
practical here mm-hmm I think I want to
target this pawn right now Oh both pawns
are hit there's only a knight move here
but you can't get there to defend and
now are they all falling move the rather
they aren't and they are all falling ah
I might I wanted to go there with my
king you dummy
bad mouse lip should still be better
here let's go to this square bad Mouse
lip very bad what do I want to have
happen here I should get rolling huh
just take like that get pushing I
wouldn't mind a knight trade I have that
under control may still do that just to
get a square let's see getting a pastor
over here two outside passers huh oh
there isn't a good Bishop check I want
to keep pressure here ten seconds though
okay I should have a
upon you have the night under control I
got that square covered three seconds
yes
1.2 I don't know we'll see what happens
point eight six can't talk it's kind of
like this see what happens here I need a
breather can I get a breather point one
three plenty of time to spare
Oh spinals been berserk and berserk in
he's back oh man okay spinal I'm still
just cooling down from last game give me
a minute give me a minute man
okay I'm ready
should I throw the same stuff at him
okay now yeah let's go well mmm
yeah make up your mind only a three
minute game all right we're takin we're
just gonna go straight in for it a
quickie pun efore push oh is that right
let's open it up Wow did not expect that
alright let's try this and then Knight
to h5 I want to make white struggle a
little bit to get this pawn and also I
have this so breaking a lot of opening
principles and do I want to just give up
both bishops and say let's just be a
trading machine let's try that didn't
get the Queen's off I guess so
alright let's try this I'm up upon I got
the knight pair don't underestimate the
knight pair very deadly if this bishop
ever hit my knight some prep work for
this point letter this push g5 could be
a bit scary doing this getting on that
diagonal I think I'll be there in time
97 and then scoot my Rick over diagonal
is scary mm-hmm that's another approach
I think I want to just take once once
bishop gonna hurt me let's find out
now if this I have a square right we
spare square notice I'm going here not
here I want to be able to get out of the
pin who those bishops are gonna be
killers I got this Knight is silly
he's just defending upon okay maybe I
don't need him exchange sacrifice should
we keep going with that that plan ah
let's see castles check here that's kind
of scary
but I think I'll be alright those
cover a lot of ground now that there
isn't pressure here this night wants to
just get back in the ball game fast
suppose I do this suppose just suppose
now let's step up here no push and then
Bishop check here I dropped the knight
that wouldn't be any good ro this and
then King here Wow um let's go here wow
did I just eat up a lot of time there am
I ever gonna get rid of this Bishop if
it goes there
and I know my back rank is really weak I
have a square at least we're missing
something yeah something fancy let's go
here one minute oh this is a double
attack against both bishops that doesn't
happen every day I think I want to just
get rid of one of them yeah okay look at
this guy he's just camping out what's
the body count one two three four five
six one two three can't even get out of
time to count let's get out of pins um
yeah let's go here I'm hitting something
I'm fine
Oh after watch I have to watch that
Bishop can move anywhere and attack my
knight let's go here for starters I want
to be able to do this it's really weird
really weird how to defend this Bishop
takes pawn maybe
I think I would have something fancy
night here 28 seconds why am I playing
so slow does this work rook there fancy
no I could I can recapture like this and
I'm there to defend oh I thought I'm up
I thought I was up a piece with that
sequence I'm dropping the farm well this
is too easy now so one King and pawn
ending okay hmm yeah I do not expect a
win in this one mmm a rat race uh I was
so confused in that one I thought I was
gonna be winning a piece why did I think
I was winning a minor piece with that
sequence hmm I'm still just I'm still
just trying to reflect on that last game
I don't know I just I clearly
miscalculated good game spy no I still I
still had hope for some kind of fancy
time burner at the end of that one you
got me back okay
either of us are playing very convincing
in our two games okay riffian defense is
this actually a thing or if in defense
from hell so let's look at the country
we have time for that remember that last
game or really all the games you played
seconds remaining use them wisely okay I
blinked and i missed my opponents move
there okay I guess we're gonna babysit
why is the rook on back you were afraid
of that mmm-hmm I'm winning a pawn now I
just wanna pond interesting imbalances
that myself and spinal had there Patrick
is really excited about b6 + b8 okay so
I have a B pun in black does not maybe I
should let the b-pawn bolt and why not
this guy is under control this guy's
under control if he's under control
what's this guy doing how does black
improve how black challenged my center
okay so some fire is being thrown at c4
I think the queen is super cozy right on
right on d3
I could have also gone here okay I like
my bishop here okay let's go beep on
yeah Oh do we keep going let's keep
going I'm going to take with the pawn
mm-hmm okay well maybe I won't be taking
with the pun it's a little bit
uncomfortable with the see file opening
up protecting c4 now converging on a 7
so I could go here maybe with the four
Queen here Knight a 7 where does the
Queen go I already have a flight square
I wouldn't mind sneaking in g3 as well
don't mind having options I think I want
an Anu
a new square for my king okay
you
oh I could take this pawn right now
you
you
I don't want to take it just yet I don't
want this diagonal to open up I want to
keep this under control I'm giving up a
nice square on c5 I'm prepared to just
knock them out as otherwise I would drop
you for both Knights are soon to
converge on that point under a minute I
think this is maybe the first game where
I am up on the clock okay let's let's
calculate a little bit we're gonna go
here because I want to be here okay now
I thought I could just take that night
now it's just more miscalculation by me
let's go here first
Oh was that really necessary
okay now have a passer and I'm up the
exchange
it's very difficult to get out of
there's two there's a lot of work black
has to do to get out of that pin there's
not enough time for clean a six next
there's no way to get the night here you
know this kind of stuff
protecting c8
so this is this is falling now we'll
take with the Queen get a queen exchange
and that's going to be that okay we're
taking out the knight pushing through
where's the mate it's close by me in one
two three I think on - oh this one's
three okay we got that one in twenty
seconds there are 126 in here who's in
first terminal is having a fantastic run
21 with fire 18 17 16 I'm still fishing
for my first four I got six and we're
almost were already at the halfway point
collet okay Wilden next opponent first
time playing this guy spinal tap is in
pause mode
bathroom break for spinal or as he had
enough okay we have a Sicilian on board
who cares about
these bathroom breaks okay Bishop here I
definitely do not want a week in the d5
square hmm okay
normally it's Bishop beats for you
keeping pressure here would certainly
make me hesitate playing Bishop d7 if
Bishop b3 because of pea sacrifices on
e6 white is playing it a bit
conservative ooh
this night these squares are really
sticking out to me
so what's the plan maybe a five or a
four
okay no well let's go here I often times
you know Queen b6 what would keep me
away from that is a counter punching
Bishop III okay going up is if the Queen
can't be that bad can it is why
vulnerable anywhere
eventually I want this but there's still
more work to do and that work involves
getting this rook playing
and okay now's the time for flights
cried you have to be careful though
these bishops are both pointing at my
king however indirect it may be now
fancy night jump
that's something how do i improve here
how about we dance how about this square
I have [ __ ] ups not here I'll be pretty
juicy okay that should be one pain of a
night
okay now this bishops eyes just opened
really wide
you
okay
how do we hurt why
hmm
just gonna kind of wait my queen a new
square if this pawn ever moves oh my
goodness you've just moved that can't be
right
I should just be winning material at
least I'm gonna go for the material take
here and I'm only doing no I shouldn't
say only I'm doing this knowing that I
could get that light square Bishop right
back now I have a big Center and these
two rooks that on this file are
basically negated by this structure I
have an unprotected bishop here I want
to kind of take care of that
once maybe go let's go here secure that
okay that square was just given up top
in there oh and this rook is cooked
that's a cooked rib in all fancy with
these do I even want that rook I don't
even know if I want that rook no I care
more about just getting rid of that not
Bishop I'm fearful this kind of stuff
I'm clueless just being up upon I don't
I don't need much yeah okay this just
want to keep it squeaky clean I'm up
upon and
I'm down on the clock I just want to
cover my base points let's get out any
fancy stuff I don't care if my
structures ruin over here I'm up a pond
and this guy is like he's half dead I'm
up a pond and a half let's target the
weak link
if this pond ever moves all of my major
pieces eyes light up
oh that was weird what just happened
what's how for a clean exchange 37
seconds this may be one of those games
that turns out to be very painful
I lose one of these controlled positions
targeting C to no clean here here we go
now she's kind of crawling up into a
ball I love that pinpointing that okay
let's let's get all the pieces playing
as much as they can like keep pressure
right here I just cracked things open
like that let's try this just try and
get at the King here insert it Chuck
let's do that all righty
I have lateral movement so okay I got
the Queen's
13 seconds though oh that's a free queen
they missed that I was on the Queen
there okay eight seconds is plenty
really is okay we're at that free move
remove the rest of this game out so now
fancy stalemates matin - one of these -
there we go okay you know I have seen
this before idea before not in that
exact position but I've seen this before
move with the intention to peel open the
Queen side with a four basically like
forcing me to capture away from the
center because White has a lot of
pressure on my b5 point with the minor
pieces but if that doesn't happen I
think it's just a liability you know if
you I don't know that's just been my
experience b4 without a continuation a
four I think there's a problem there
it's inconsistent c3 and c4 weaknesses
are a bit too much okay
well black did not support d5 with a
pond so eventually I want this guy
running but not too fast Knight c3
Knight f3 before efore is important
because here and then here it can be met
with the e5 okay to give the knight a
shout do I know
Bishop knows its place I'm gonna hold
off on hmm let's just go here if the
bishop got okay bishops not gonna go
here being cutout time huh
and let's baby city for um I think I
know where the bishop wants to be not
here cuz that's a desirable move for
black okay and this was my idea have
this structure negate the bishop can
this be maintained I think so this would
be really weakening trying to break that
down also
if here I get to take and then shatter
the kingside structure that can't be
healthy for this guy okay we're gonna go
with rookie a I don't know I don't think
there's any action going on on the C
file so I'm going to commit the Queen
rook given some time I'll sneak in a
flight square I'm not sure if we're at
that point just yet 22 minutes left this
tournament man does it fly by so what
does black do the kind of stock right
you try and secure square for your queen
or play a form maybe rook c8 here rook
ca
each six clean they're okay trying for
that I try and pounce at the c7 square
let's just do that and play something
quick force the Queen to go back
rook here I could maybe go pawn hunting
okay
well that's an interesting move um yeah
that's that's a pretty interesting move
but you know we're gonna break here
there's there's the idea of Knight f4
and also to kind of give my knight a
shove so this must be one giant pest on
d6 now Bishop c6 I'm anticipating
getting some squares now this this isn't
giving up the light square bishop huh
it's interesting all right I'll hunt
down the bishop pair and I think I want
another night on d6 one night is good a
second night is good I don't think I'm
gonna be too vulnerable if I do this
yeah I know
okay he's unprotected but I don't know
how you could really take advantage of
this I wouldn't mind some exchanges in
the end I always have this positive
bishop pair it's not going away anytime
soon
mmm I don't see a dark square bishop
exchange happening
okay well now this rook is unprotected
so there is no ninety five might try and
shove my Knight d5 oof we get at the
king stabilize secure my Knight Queen b3
is always a move Bishop c4 Queen b3
combining a chat ok so now this squared
is given up now we're going to try and
bring the pain and it's close by Queen B
3 or Bishop c4 mm-hmm what's better I'll
go with Bishop c4 I want to just kind of
keep my queen around to defend some
squares so I'm getting the exchange have
to take otherwise I take here next with
check also down on time jfn and I hear
you still can't do that the rook is
unprotected all right let's just pull
the bishop back and well it's now
prepared to double here we go yes
they're gonna drop time yes okay I got
12 I got my first 4 it took took six
games I'm in 16th far away from terminal
who's having a great run let's see who
we get next if I get a 16 maybe that
would put me on the front page yeah but
all these other games could finish they
could be gaining way in Prinze first
time playing this opponent Kings Indian
let's let's give Bishop d3 a whirl okay
space so how
black try and combat this pawn be six
try and bypass
okay well b5 is not a threat well I just
want to eliminate that even as a pawn
sacrifice the other move I was gonna do
is this all right I'm gonna mmm I want
to open it up and I think I want to go
for a pawn sacrifice just to split these
guys up too strong so I'm giving up a
pawn in order for what in order to do
what to gain access to e4 I'm not
threatening to win this what would I
like to have happen what piece don't
want to play against I think I'm
prepared to give up the dark square
bishop hmm why though why would I do
that okay um let's let's go here no I
don't want to be too quick to give up
the dark square Bishop you know here's
the thing that night could be pretty
invasive what what kept me from trying
something like that it are these two
squares become wonderful outpost for
Brooks definitely this one this is a
hole I could control this but it's not
without some fear yeah my opponents
ready to occupy that really nice
diagonal so let me just anticipate that
I have the better Bishop that's the
other thing so this is this is my bad
bishop just I guess really this is the
the key structure I'm looking at in
order to define the good and bad bishops
in this case even on the clock so if the
returns I guess I'm gonna fly back well
number was on g2 but I will be Fein
Kettering let's do this
anticipating some pressure against f2
mm-hmm let's drop back mm-hmm all right
what's this rook doing nothing
still down upon okay so huh could I do
this Bishop takes pawn Bishop takes
Bishop Bishop takes rook is there a
great Bishop move bishop h3 Bishop takes
Bishop I'm gonna be a little greedy hmm
proceed with caution for sure giving up
this super valuable Bishop on but this
Bishop can turn into pac-man so
eventually you have to stop this now
you're gonna rescue this guy I will also
be eliminating this Bishop but I want
yeah okay so I have to be super careful
now because my light squares really weak
so I just want to kind of take some
steps to stop the Queen from even seeing
g2 I'm also opening up my kingdom check
I think that this is just a really
really important move okay we'll go here
scary
I get the Queen's up
move night Queen takes pawn yeah let's
just go straight in for this Queen takes
pawn with check definitely have to stop
that hmm oh my god you know what there
was this move and I think I was dead oh
wow
lucky it was very lucky I think Queen
here two different main threats as well
as Queen takes f3 I'm I'm on the rook
the Queen can't go too far yeah it's
scary let's come over here yeah feel
like I'm gonna blunder okay could maybe
Mike my queen just sit here for forever
why am I going into this pin anybody
know 9 seconds hey I don't mind seeing
that for seconds oh man I should have
played it simpler I knew I was suck I
knew I was signing up for that giving up
that light square bishop not a very good
practical decision yeah I think my mind
was locked on you know this this is
probably objectively ok but yeah
practically not really a good idea I had
to chew up so much time trying to defend
stuff and I think Queen Queen f2 was a
backbreaker
who
duh you check that one out yeah I think
that that was a backbreaker Queen takes
out three Bishop g2 queen g2 just too
many threats and I don't have enough
moves to defend them all all right so
what's the plan here neglect the whole
Queen side okay we have an idea though
the idea is to get upon any form all
right
and what are we doing next we're going
to continue to try and develop here
okay
and Bishop here yeah I have to watch out
I definitely need to hang out of the d4
upon
I can't let you go maybe I could
kill me
my opponent might be going for my throat
what did I do to deserve this
you
let's go to
I went one there's this backup and then
this and I think I want I think I want
it you know I want to win upon if
they're gonna go with a break
all right this night needs to get
playing I don't know how else he does it
dropping upon night here was was pretty
nice
oh boy
right here
is probably pretty excited now
could go here I don't know this is kind
of scary here just as a pawn sacrifice
rook
you know make me on h8 connecting with
the bishop this isn't a variation to
revisit alright
this Knight has has something to say
about this diagonal
there you go
I care about that
a bishop probably
much though enough
enough
all right let's let's maybe look at some
forward squares here huh I have a night
that can maybe drop into one of these
two
I know here
yeah I don't I don't want to give a give
up that punim where's the king in ago
why is why keeping me guessing for so
long
give me this information okay I
definitely need to secure this diagonal
doesn't have a point here anymore okay
so no there has to be something juicy
soon let's go here this is aimed at
preventing this majority from rolling
it's a three versus two now and let's
let's maybe threaten g5 went upon I
think I want to sacrifice something over
here okay we're gonna push we're gonna
we're going to go pawn hunting I have
this secured and I'm winning h3 now
I have this square covered by my knight
I'm getting rid of the well we saw how
important that light square bishop was
in the last game
so they decline
you
mhm
well
I need to do something fast 45 seconds
all right let's since maybe continue
like this
Square why did I do that
I want to get rid of some apiece some of
the pieces around the king I want my
queen over here
I want this night to to hit hard when
and this night makes its next move I
want something fantastic to happen
maybe that's something fantastic my
bishop here here here here mate
do I have all those moves I could try
other nights the nights actually they
are defending
Wow it's tough to keep track of all
these minor pieces
give up that dark square bishop can I
can I sneak in here
Oh 15 seconds
why can I not get my clean over there
I could pivot here the bishops
unprotected
okay
you
I want to get rid of that I only have
six seconds
you
No
ah down time ah man I found it so bad in
that one really bad
man I don't know why couldn't wrap my
head around how to get my queen
activated near their King ah man
that one hurts that one definitely hurts
I felt like I had zero play in the whole
game on that one
that was really bad okay yeah I'm not
one to revisit for sure I was lucky to
win upon and man
did not like how I proceeded after that
okay what could I do here
I got the bishop pair
I think my knight wants f6
hmm
the poorer apiece
Oh at the peace
just keep my dark
Bishop's eyes opened oh yeah let's go
here could offer Queen exchange
I wouldn't mind just camping out on this
square let's go here straight away
this pawn is pinned try and soften up
this structure now let's go straight in
for it alright let's open it up
alright that's pinpoint b3 how's that
defended some rook lift all right
definitely better in this position get
to a - well it's a piece may resign no
we're getting some more material now
skewer okay and it should be crumbling
now check I'll go here and get the
bishop
if they take care get to that back ring
okay now we want to clean here the move
that I think was gonna kill me in that
one game queen f2 okay let's just throw
the pigs on there on two don't hurt me
here got a mate in one threat can't
really defend it okay they resigned back
to tournament 228 one game left
maybe it's my people that might have
been my last game I don't think another
one is gonna count
I have 18 points if you're wondering top
is at 38 that might have been it no we
got the salt man I was thinking is the
first time I'm playing against assault
man not the case alright salt my him oh
he's just trying to see what kind of
reaction he gets out of me
look at that King fanciness okay let's
hop into some holes oh yeah oh yeah
these look at these squares that not
gonna hurt me I got space I love it more
space I want to kick that
night away wants to do it now where's
that nightgown let's just take all the
space at night night is a beast okay
my opponents are really asking for it
checker Oni and if I go here there's a
piece there's a sacrifice or I'm sorry
they could give up the bishop or the
Queen for a bishop and a rook no rush
one square here but I have this as a
threat next move tournament is over this
will be the last one be taking with this
pawn right now let's round of like this
I'm not even
material with this sequence I thought it
was winning material oh boy oh man I
hope I have at least a upon am i up upon
the salt man I this game even going on
still I mean I should have I should have
done something much better as my point I
should have done something a lot better
this isn't the way you punished what
black did here oh man if the knight
moves I have a I have something fancy
okay let's let's hunt down upon okay
some activity my Knights gluing
everything together though he's happy
about that still got this space to run
with the a pawn now yeah let's go a pond
let's keep going
I
I'm close to not being better soon I
want to do this and maybe grab seasick
just get out of a pen
okay Wow
the salt man and I guess we have to do
it like this d4 is under control 20
ticks for the salt man okay in the end I
guess we're gonna have the rooks sneaky
salt man very sneaky but still I'm going
here oh is that about okay stay on the
dark square that way this guy doesn't
hurt you less than five I'm glad to have
this tournament over okay let's keep
going
all right no time for the salt man
okay back determine that one took a
while how many games we get in there
that counted for the tournament not many
nine ten total games played nine counted
one 72 and all I finished in eighteenth
first page had someone at 42 no I did
play this person once not in the
tournament top three forty two thirty
nine thirty five a four was I was
fishing for four for too long okay let's
have a look at all the pages how's that
showing up on the stream okay there we
go
page two
three or 18 pages in all I guess
Oh spinal spinal had enough after just
after just five already the candy
Chessmaster and yeah some who just
played a handful and said no thanks to
the rest or didn't even play at all
okay to the 171 of you it games
you